well the magic Merkin ride has come to
an end
Jackie [ __ ] so close how are you
feeling about your ride though overall
high I'm feeling great I am so proud of
what I did on the show I'm proud I
lasted as long as I did
you know I think root kept saving me
because she saw something in me and I'm
so glad I was able to stay I can stick
around and you know keep doing drag
right that's I think we go on the show
because we love doing drag and we love
doing it on this amazing platform on TB
and so I'm glad I got to do it for 12
weeks in everyone's living room you know
so that was definitely something I'm so
proud of and yeah you know I guess it
wasn't my time but I'm still so happy
with what I did I mean you should be
happy you've been such a standout this
season it's been so fun to watch not
only the journey of you know competing
as a queen but kind of like the journey
of discovering Jackie and learning
things about yourself
stay in the game did your family get a
chance to watch have they been tuning in
week to week yes so both of my parents
aren't like super like TV people so my
dad has cable and so he's been kind of
watching but his main complaint is like
it's like well I don't like it when
you're not on the screen so he's like
just watches it and like fast-forward to
the other part and he's like I don't
know what's happening and I'm like
because dad you're skipping everyone
else's part like it's a competition it's
not just me so like that's kind of my
dad's reaction of course you know my mom
as you guys saw in the reunion you know
had a little bit more of a awakening to
what it is I do and it actually opened
up an amazing dialogue for us but you
know she's still my mom and she's still
you know her her thoughts are okay well
are you gonna make money with doing this
and do you need to share this much of
your personal life on TV but you know I
couldn't have asked for a more amazing
opportunity for me to share this with
her in a way
cuz I am so proud of what I did and
proud of how I shared our cultural
heritage and that was something that
kind of helped open the door for my mom
kind of understanding why I do drag did
she have a reaction to your impression
of her what is DS I do not approve of
these s Pais cares this is too sexy
Maxie go to your room and go study your
book on male anatomy well you don't have
to tell me twice
I think that's kind of where the like
did you have to do all of that kind of
thought came in but you know I think
it's still it's still all very new to
her and I know she hasn't been like
watching it every week but luckily you
know she gets little Clips here and
there that she kind of kindaichi s and
you know she's never liked my pression
of her I used to do it when I was the
kid and she'd be like I don't talk like
that and I'm like you definitely do mom
and I love you for it
and I think you know she's an incredible
woman who learned you know three
different languages and is able to speak
in them really well and it's it's
amazing right so you know for me to kind
of poke fun at that it's also to say
like this is still an incredible woman
and I'm so proud of her and everything
she's done at being an immigrant to this
country so I think she knows it was said
with love when you kind of got to almost
have like a love letter moment to her
with wearing the hijab on the main stage
which was such an empowering moment I
think for you and people watching at
home what I found interesting is Jeff
Goldblum got a little backlash isn't
this an interesting wrinkle though is
there something in that religion that is
anti-homosexuality and anti a woman Wow
does that complicate the issue I'm just
raising you know thinking out loud maybe
being stupid what did you make of the
backlash you know what I've thought
about that moment is is is that I'm so
happy it happened because I'm happy that
I was able to go on national television
on an American national television
and you know the world stage and kind of
make a visual statement of the
visibility of not just Muslim people but
queer Muslim people or queer people in
the Middle Eastern Diaspora of which
there are so much misinformation so much
kind of a real you know negative
portrayal in Western media in general
right the point that I wanted to bring
up is that you know the the oppressive
regimes of Iran and other countries are
something completely separate from
people's personal relationships to their
own faith or their own way to express
their cultural heritage art is something
totally different
right than a policy in Iran which could
lead to the death penalty for gay people
so it is a complicated topic and I'm
glad I was able to use a platform like
drag race to bring it to people's living
rooms and homes where you know maybe
they aren't really keyed into all of
that intersectionality and how
complicated it is and how it can all
live inside one person at the same time
yeah to take a turn from the heads were
you surprised if and everybody was
crushing on you out of drag this season
yes damn jack is hot I definitely to see
whether all these who must go because
come on bubble but I think I definitely
did not anticipate that but you know uh
whatever some tickets I guess I'd be I'm
honored that there's so many people find
my mid 30s skinny dadbod to be something
they're into you know I think it just
goes to show that like not everyone has
to be you know a physique God you know
there's someone for everyone so if I'm
people's cup of tea Thanks thank you
that that's very flattering I have a
feeling that all stars is probably in
your future at some point what would you
want to redeem yourself for some
redemption on
all-star season I mean I think there's a
couple things that the easiest wads off
the bat are you know I think I got to
step it up in my runways I don't know if
any of my runways were a real slam dunk
for the judges I mean I loved everything
I put out there and I loved my garments
and I loved those lands I worked with
and I loved the concepts but I think
just taking those little hints of
fashion I don't think of myself as the
most fashionable person but maybe
bringing in a little more of that
fashion I'm bringing some more kind of a
bad feeling to some of my runways would
definitely be a good redemption for me
and then in terms of the challenges I
noticed that part of the reason I think
I won three improv based mini challenges
which I had no time to prepare for is
that bru really connected to that side
of me just the like say whatever's off
the top of my head side and she wanted
me to break into that a little more so
that's always gonna be something that I
can think about honing into if I ever
got the chance to do it all again
because you know I love your hanging
those big belly laughs from Roo and I
heard a lot of them in the mini
challenges so okay just if I just heard
a couple more in the main challenges
like a win is there anything from this
season that you feel you need to
apologize for I think I need to
apologize for choosing Jada last in the
one-woman show challenge it should not
have been her to me this was one of the
most terrifying things that ever
happened in my life and family has it's
played out in front of y'all yard me
black but that's alright this season a
mini challenge that we didn't really get
to see was the library challenge I know
you guys sometimes keep notebooks of
like thoughts that pop up reads you
would like to share in the future do you
have one that you didn't get to use that
you would want to share now oh this is
this is what I wrote which is not great
but I'll tell you anyway it's it's - its
- my dear sis Widow Vaughn do and the
way the read would go is Widow you are a
fierce performer and I can tell that
after this you're gonna have a huge solo
career which must be why your heels are
so low
not comedy so maybe it's a good thing
that challenge did it make it watch TV
screen I don't know I would have liked
to have seen that play out in the room
before I let you go is there any quote
from this season that sticks out to you
any moment that you'll be quoting
forever from this season
you hear me quoting it a lot during the
season which is uh from our dearly
departed Aidan Zane boo boo
I think boo is incredible I think
actually it's because of us that the
that the producers even realized it was
a thing so we all just started saying it
and then at one point one of them asked
us they said why do you keep saying boo
and I'm like because I even said it it
was so funny at least it was to me so
I'll just keep saying boo boo well I'm
excited for everyone to see the finale
and hopefully we get more two of Jackie
Cox on our TVs in the future hey I'm
very available and I have a ring life so
call me hi Murphy call me
[Music]